la réflexion le débat c'est selon le
point de vue diane guilbaud et
présidente du mouvement pour les droits
des femmes et alain roy professeur de
droit à la faculté de droit de
l'université de montréal et en 2015 on a
parlé de faire les rois vous allez
présenter un rapport sur le droit de la
famille à la demande du gouvernement est
il recommandé entre autres qu'on précise
ce genre de situation et le bel le
rapport est toujours cela faibles et
temps de trajet de la semaine dernière
bonsoir à tous les deux
alors peut-être que je commençais calme
avec la dimension juridique on parle de
caractère criminel de la rétribution
ceci qu ottawa il ya québec aussi qu'un
rôle à jouer un côté ville qui dit
quelque chose très succinctement qu'est
ce qui est permis ou pas ici au canal
surtout qu'avant tandis que 500 maires
qui participent à une agence et qui
favorise la gestation pour autrui
oui en fait que le code civil dit c'est
que les ententes de mères porteuses sont
nulles de nuit' absolue ce qui veut dire
qu'on peut pas en obtenir l'exécution
forcée devant un tribunal donc si après
l'accouchement la mère porteuse ne veut
pas remettre l'enfant
le couple d'intention peut pas
s'adresser au tribunal et vice versa
c'est à dire aussi les parents
d'intention ne veulent pas l'enfant la
mère porteuse ne peut pas les forcer à
prendre l'enfant c'est la première
conséquence de nullité absolue
la deuxième c'est que la filiation de
l'enfant va être établie en fonction des
règles normales c'est à dire des règles
qui régissent la filiation dit par le
sang c'est la mère porteuse qui sera la
mère et par la suite si à un homme dans
le couple d'intention lui pourra
signaler déclaration de naissance et
devenir père de l'enfant et après coup
si tout le monde est d'accord pour que
l'enfant puisse être transférée au
couple et de façon plus précise à la
conjointe du père pour jouer parce que
dites-vous aux conjoints effectivement
il ya un consentement à l'adoption qui
pourrait être donnée par la mère
porteuse en faveur de la merde et ans la
terraudière melatti les tribunaux québec
ont pu misère avec ça
oui mais ça s'est clarifiée la ces
derniers temps on a on a vraiment tracé
7 voilà qui permet finalement de
parachever le contrôle et la
criminalisation il y en a eu une contre
une agence à se demander si le
gouvernement fédéral croit vraiment à
sa loi et à l'interdiction de
rétribution tout le monde sait qui a des
contrats de mère porteuse qui soit en
titre onéreux mais comme par hasard il
n'y a pas de poursuite alors quelque
chose qui marche pas d'autant qu' il ya
un règlement qui devait être adopté pour
baliser la compensation que la mère
porteuse pour recevoir la loi date de
2004 le règlement jamais été adopté ce
qui entraîne une confusion ou un certain
flou entre ce qui est une rémunération
ou ceux qui une simple compensation
est-ce que diane guilbault ce reportage
qu'on fait pour vous dans votre esprit
parce que vous êtes contre toutes formes
d'industrialisation en fait de
commercialisation du mort de l'enfant
qu'il ya bel et bien au canada en ce
moment une forme d'industrie or
absolument est une industrie qui est un
grand essor le gouvernement fédéral n'en
fait pas de cachette non plus à
l'automne dernier il a fait une
consultation auprès de l'industrie c'est
comme ça que ça s'appelait consultation
près de l'industrie où on parlait entre
autres de la traçabilité des produits
et ça comprend le tout ce qui le tout ce
qui va amener à avoir un bébé au bout
d'une laisse prise au vél exactement
donc on est vraiment dans
l'industrialisation et c'est c'est la
conséquence logique de partir de là
l'autorisation de la légalisation de la
pratique parce qu'à partir du moment où
on permet de
la pratique du recours aux mères
porteuses et c'est sûr qu'il va manquer
une mère porteuse parce que ça n'a pas
beaucoup de femmes qui vont accepter de
porter un enfant pour quelqu'un d'autre
comme ça alors donc pour alimenter et
soutenir ce marché que l'industrie
développe et nourrit alors on passe à la
rémunération ils en demandant aux
députés de faire le petit bout de chemin
pour permettre légaliser la
commercialisation total 100 sans entrave
et faciliter la développement d'une
industrie qu'on considère comme étant
avantageuse pour les katas et ce sans
parler du tourisme de procréation en
inde ou ailleurs et on connaît les
conditions dans lesquelles le saut
tourisme l'os se déroulent ces des
couloirs ni plus ni moins dans
lesquelles les mères porteuses
interviennent ou sont recueillis pendant
neuf mois et ce qui est particulièrement
troublant dans cette idée de
rémunération c'est le rapport de
servitude qui se crée entre la mère
porteuse et le couple d'intention et
quand on parle de libre choix parce que
c'est un argument conscience faveur elle
est fan des manuels et ils ont la
liberté la libre disposition de leur
corps alors pourquoi est ce qu'on les
empêcherait de portée moyennant
rémunération
si je paye une mère porteuse cent mille
dollars
j'aurais certainement d attente légitime
quant à son comportement pendant la
grossesse c'est d'ailleurs la mère
porteuse que vous avez interview
autrement appelée more interviews oui le
disait si elle se nourrit bien mais
justement si elle se nourrit pas bien
oui alors moi j'aurais certainement d
attente pour lui dire non tu ne fume pas
je ne bois pas tu manges convenablement
tu ne sors pas aussi à du verglas est
l'ultime conséquences en matière
d'interruption de grossesse
si la mère porteuse je me dis bah je
veux exercer mon droit fondamental de
médecins la grossesse et changer au bout
de deux mois trois bras et je lui ai
versé 100 mille dollars
je vais m'attendre à ce qu'on me
rembourse mon 100 mille dollars
et si elle ne peut pas me rembourser sa
décision ne sera pas libre à poursuivre
sa grossesse avec cette épée de damoclès
qui vient tous contaminés finalement la
rémunération est écrit ce rapport de
servitude et de dépendances
vous soulevez un point aussi diane
guilbault suite à l'intervention dans
l'hérault à ces cas là le grand nord
fédéral ne semble pas beaucoup croire à
sa loi
décriminalisation est soulevée par le
député mais c'est à se demander si c'est
celle où poster projet de loi parce que
dans les faits c'est comme s'ils avaient
pas de criminalisation du comportement
il y en a pas de toute façon même le
gouvernement fait de la promotion du
produit tourisme procréatif via ses
ambassades
oui on peut trouver dans l'est par
exemple sur le site web de l'ambassade
du canada au mexique une liste d'avocats
qui vont nous faciliter l'accès à des
mères porteuses qu'on pourra parler
absolument oui alors on a des photos ici
alors écoutez une annonce est troublant
de voir l'attitude du canada dans cette
dans ce dossier là et évidemment c'est
évident que le gouvernement ne croit pas
à sa loi
mais pour le moment c'est une domination
de la décriminalisation pas en groupe
parce que le recours amène
automatiquement
c'est la conséquence c'est la suite
logique de la légalisation de la
pratique même si c'est non onéreux ou
que la mère dit qu'elle le fait pour
autrui une soeur fait ça pour une femme
fait ça pour sa soeur bon ça c'est très
rare y aurait pas d'industrie c'était ça
la situation ce n'est pas sur la
situation
c'est un marché mondial c'est une
industrie mondiale avec beaucoup
d'argent est rompu une autre soeur
finalement il ya des groupes et beaucoup
de pays qui l'ont interdit carrément il
ya des idées organisation qui lutte pour
l'abolition universelle parce que ça
peut pas être localement que ces
décisions se font c'est un marché
international
alors donc il faut que ce soit des
décisions internationales et il ya
plusieurs pays notamment en europe qui
interdisent la pratique
alors il ya ici les français viennent
ici là on en avait justement il ya un
cas qui étaient confiées comme ça à
l'adoption parce qu'on a vu que c'était
vraiment un trafic d'enfants
mais le pour lutter contre une pratique
internationale
il faut des lois internationales
l'équivalent de la convention de la haye
pour l'adoption
en fait il faudrait avoir l'équivalent
pour empêcher le recours aux mères
porteuses
et vous vous avez d'approcher un peu
différentes de celles venant bilbo
laquelle en fait moi je suis contre la
rémunération de la mère porteuse pour
les raisons que j'ai évoquées tantôt
mêmes que je pense que le gouvernement
fédéral s'y croyait vraiment sa loi la
rendre extraterritoriale pour faire
avant sauf quand il s'est appliqué à des
couples d'ici qui s'en vont en inde
alors non on se retranche derrière le
caractère national de la loi pour dire
on n'a pas de prise sur ces couples là
et on ne peut pas leur appliquer les
sanctions
le québec est le fédéral federer cela
dit si c'est fait à titre gratuit 6 et
altruiste et les recherches tendent à
démontrer que il ya effectivement des
femmes qui le font dans le but d'aider
un couple infertile
moi je me soucie de l'enfant qui va
naître de la mère porteuse
c'est enfin pour responsables des
circonstances de sa naissance
et si on ne veut pas revenir à l'époque
des enfants illégitimes ou naturels
on ne peut pas le priver du droit à la
filiation qu'il peut légitimement
revendiquer avec les parents d'intention
c'est à dire sur qui ont nourri ce désir
d'enfant et ceux qui sont partis au
projet parental parce qu'autrement on va
faire quoi de cet enfant là on le met en
adoption
et il va pouvoir être adoptés par la
caisse a conscience et vous avez dit
cela et au québec c'était assez régler
le processus d'adoption pour ses enfants
le comité consultatif sur le droit de la
famille que j'ai présidé 2013 à 2015
me repose qu'on puisse établir un cadre
juridique clair spécifique aux mères
porteuses de la même manière qu'on en
retrouve dans d'autres pays et dans les
provinces canadiennes
alors si toutes les parties sont
toujours d'accord après l'accouchement
pour que l'enfant puisse être transférée
aux parents d'intention alors sur la
déclaration de naissance on pourrait
avoir les trois signatures et l'acte de
naissance de l'enfant pour être émis au
nom des parents d'intention plutôt que
de passer par l'adoption qui est une
procédure plein de trous qui ne convient
pas parce qu'elle n'est pas
spécifiquement pensés en fonction de ce
scénario
alors il ya moyen d'en venir à établir
la filiation de sept enfants avec les
personnes qu'ils ont des effets et qui
dans les faits vont le prendre en charge
vous n'êtes pas d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord parce qu'à partir du moment où
les tribunaux aval avalise une pratique
qui est qui s'est fait illégalement on
encourage la poursuite alors nous on
pense qu'il faut qu'il ya des signale
des signaux clairs qu'ils soient donnés
et puis que le tribunal il ya eu un
jugement en première instance avait
décrété effectivement que l'enfant ne le
devaient
ne devrait pas être remis à un des
parents d'attac d'intention mais la cour
d'appel renversé ce jugement mais nous
on pense que j'ai pris par les parents
d'être nous on appelle alors nous on
pense qu'il faut interdire vraiment la
pratique totalement découragé la pl la
prise de mettre devant le juge de mettre
le jugement excusez moi devant un fait
accompli c'est à dire un enfant et
l'enfant qui a été conçue peut être
confiant l'adoption parce
qu'actuellement on dit le parents
d'intention souvent c'est le père il en
lien génétique mais en 1989 quand jean
guy tremblay réclamaient des droits sur
le l'enfant de chantal daigle le jeu joe
bien décrété que le père n'avait pas le
pearl le géniteur n'avait pas c'était
pas ça crée son droit à l'enfant et on
pense à la demande à voir mais d'ici là
il a le droit à des parents parce que
c'est sur l'adoption l'adoption c'est le
droit de l'enfant est d'avoir des
parents alors non pas que les parents
avoir un enfant c'est très différent
vous dit peut-être avoir des parents les
tensions devraient confirmer la
reconnaissance génétique de ce temps
fort de cette filiation biologique dans
un autrement on se trouve à se servir de
l'enfant pour sanctionner les parents
d'intention alors dit vous avez agi de
façon immorale et pour vous punir on va
vous retirez cet enfant là et on va le
confier à n'importe qui d'autre qu'à
vous alors que souvent l'enfant le
bagage génétique de ces personnes qui
veut il veut savoir d'où ils viennent et
viole le droit à la connaissance des
origines de julien en terminant beat
juridique ou pas en ce moment
selon vous les sens tension confusion
juridique il divo à québec il ya un gros
problème il ya un flou on un mécanisme
qui est pas adapté et au fédéral le flou
c'est quand à la rétribution versus la
compensation on est dans le flou total
et l'année le non respect de la loi
fédérale qui existent déjà être pas du
tout à faire avancer le dossier
responsabilités gouvernementales autant
aux 3 kg merci design guilbaud merci
alain roy alors je me dis que ce
reportage que vous pouvez voir ôter le
jour dans ce soir de ma collègue
madeleine des morins sur la gestation
pour autrui et le fait que sur un
portage lève le voile sur un monde qu'on
ne connaît pas vraiment
sur cette industrie alors avoir au
téléjournal merci tous l'aider merci à
vous